My favorite budget deck list was built
in under 10 minutes and it changed how I
built decks forever. It started with me
thinking about how metal rocks are
powerful. Hot take. I know. I was a bit
of a hipster. So, I wanted to build a
deck filled with metal rocks. But the
problem was that you're playing really,
really high risk and your deck,
especially your commander, has to be
high reward. It needs to be able to
recoup all that card advantage lost, but
anything following that play pattern is
just way too fast and powerful. So, the
idea was set aside until Hour of
Devastation brought us this card, Unesh,
Sphinx, Sovereign. This is the answer I
was waiting for. It will take advantage
of all the mana rocks and draw us cards,
but can't do anything too broken
because, well, we are stuck with
sphinxes. Now that we have a commander,
this is when the timer starts.
The main reason this was quick was
because I decided that metal rocks,
lands, and sphinxes were all I wanted in
this deck. It just felt right. There's
just a certain appeal to simple and
effective decks. And we got the simple
part down. For the deck to be effective,
I needed to figure out the right ratio.
And since I never built anything even
remotely close to this, I just picked
the most balanced approach to test and
adjust later. 33 lands, 33 rocks, and 33
sphinxes.
Let's go. Okay, let's begin. Search
skyfall for sphinxes, sphines, monol,
and uh Sphinx.
All righty. And uh let's let's have a
budget restriction, right? Let's not go
over $10.
Seems good. Go
rank by EDH.
Let's pick pretty much the best ones.
Second Sun. Beautiful. Uh we don't do
artifacts. Don't know. Good. Uh we don't
need card draw. Good, good, excellent.
Dream eater.
Sphinx of Gatun. Big dom. Sure. Oh, this
one is a win condition. We don't have
spells, but we can recur our mana rocks,
I guess. Seems good. Good. Excellent.
Low cost is always good. Three more.
Sure. Riddle keeper. This guy is nice.
Her derp. I'm a swings. We are at 34.
Time for mana rocks. Yeah, once again we
keep the budget restriction and uh
artifact add. I'm pretty sure we have to
prioritize the low cost ones. So we
start with let's say two mana value. Yes
rank by EDH wreck.
Nice. Nice. Sure. Yeah, this is good.
Stark comp is good. Let's go to three
drops.
Whoops. I
adh rank
go plus one plus one seems good. Two
mana seems good. We do need this effect
because we are going to mail ourselves
with what three or four mini faces a
turn. So this seems really good. Plus
one to our swings. Sure. Oh, we should
play the bobbleheads. How many
bobbleheads are there? Five. Okay,
bubble bobblehead time. One, two,
bobblehead. Three. Bobblehead. Five.
Six. Number seven. Okay, there's seven
of them, I guess. Okay, we are at 63
cards. We need just how many more? Three
more. Uh, let's look at four drops. No,
we need four more, I think. Yeah, four
more rocks. Four drop.
Go. Go.
Dynamo is good.
Archive. We don't need draw. Oh, Nick's
Lotus is nutty. I thought this was more
expensive, but seems good. Oh, and then
there's Soaring. We are at 66.
Okay, let's just add one more three mana
one. There was one that I liked when I
saw it. Stricks Haven Stadium. Yeah,
this one I like. Okay,
sweet. Okay, this took a while. The mana
rocks. We're at 67 cards, but we've got
the easy part now.
Island.
Boom.
[Music]
And we have a deck.
Boom.
And that was an reenactment of how the
deck came together. I remember the
entire process being 10 minutes because
I was picking up singles at MTG Mint
Cards in Hong Kong. Great store. And
they were near closing time. Now, I've
been playing this deck for years. I've
made some changes. land for land, swings
for sphinx, but the ratio of 33 33 33
was never touched. It performed well.
Now, I know the deck would probably
benefit from a counter spell or two or
some removals, board wipes even, but
there's just something about this
minimalistic deck building that really
appeals to me. Nowadays, we are
overwhelmed with choices between the
deck building templates and all the
pushed utility they're releasing. It's
difficult for even the most experienced
deck builder to stay on course with the
core philosophy of their deck, the
reason they built it in the first place.
But if we cut out all that noise and
just focus on what we want to do, we do
one thing well and force our opponents
to deal with it. There's just a certain
satisfaction in being completely
transparent with others knowing exactly
what you can do and will do yet still
having trouble stopping you. Since
Zunes, I've built other decks with a
similar philosophy, a get rock ravenous
ride deck with just manadors, pump
spells, and protection spells, or an
Evelyn the coous deck with mana rocks,
protection spells, and clones. Now, this
is a topic I wish to expand upon in the
future. And if you're still here, I'd
love to hear your thoughts. Are you
interested? Do you see the appeal in
this kind of deck building? Do you have
decks that follow this philosophy? If
you love this content, subscribe for
more. And if you don't, uh, subscribe as
well and constantly remind me of how
much you hate it.